As of filming this video, about 250 thousand
of you watched my recent hour long sit down
with Colin Moriarity from YouTube Week.
Colin is best known as a gaming journalist
and one of the founders and host of Kinda
Funny, a popular gaming talk show.
I actually didn't know much about Colin before
our YouTube Week chat beyond a couple interactions
we had on Twitter.
My intention with the interview was actually
to get away from politics and focus on my
long lost love of video games, but within
a minute I could tell how passionate Colin
was about current events and the political
world.
Sometimes an interview you expect one thing
from, but get something totally different
is the best kind, and in Colin's interview,
this was absolutely the case.
Right after the interview, I told Colin that
he could be a major conservative political
star if he ever wanted to go that route.
A few days after our initial interview, Colin's
world went completely bonkers.
Colin posted a rather benign joke on Twitter
(Show tweet) on International Women's Day.
The tweet got thousands of retweets and favorites,
but of course also caused backlash by the
Bigoteers always looking to be outraged.
By the way, the joke itself, as Colin said,
isn't the smartest of funniest thing ever,
it's actually a really simple line that every
sitcom from I Love Lucy to Married With Children
to Everybody Loves Raymond has been based
on.
Regardless of whether it was funny or not,
a firestorm of outrage began and within a
couple days Colin stepped down from Kinda
Funny, the company he co-owned and the show
he co-created with his friends.
Regardless of whether the joke was funny,
or sexist or just stupid...which are all subjective
feelings, the point is that the out of control
firestorm was once again on the attack.
The online gaming media jumped all over Colin,
in one case claiming he had gone on a right
wing talk show known as The Rubin Report to
discuss the tweet.
Of course in reality, we had taped and aired
the show about a week before he posted the
tweet in the first place.
The worst case of journalistic dishonesty
came not from a gaming site though, but from
a mainstream outlet, the International Business
Times.
Let's look at this headline:
KINDA FUNNY'S COLIN MORIARTY RESIGNS AFTER
TARGETING WOMEN IN A RACIST JOKE; INSISTS
IT'S HIS PERSONAL DECISION
To say this is beyond the pale doesn't even
begin to describe it.
This social justice warrior disease, combined
with a pinch of intersectionality and a sprinkling
of misguided outrage has a mainstream publication
accusing Colin of racism where there literally
was not word word of racism in the tweet.
Eventually I was able to track down an editor
of IB Times, who I passed to Colin and they
changed the headline about 24 hours later.
Too little, too late, though, and the damage
was done.
Just imagine if that had been you for a moment.
This is what I mean when I say this regressive
movement will come for all of us.
I suspect coming for private citizens for
wrongthink is next, just wait and see.
After all of this nonsense, I did a second
interview with Colin, live streamed out to
you with no editing, to clean up the mess.
Colin respectfully and honestly told his side
of the story, without throwing his friends
and former co-workers under the bus.
We also took a ton of questions from you,
and shared a really intimate moment of friendship
on camera.
When the interview finished, I really felt
like we had done something relevant and important.
Together we stood up against the outrage machine,
against the misguided social justice movement
and more importantly, we stood up for something...for
ourselves...and if we won't stand for ourselves
then why would anyone else stand for us?
Now this is where this really gets good.
Last week Colin launched his own Patreon to
fund his new show aptly titled Colin's Last
Stand.
As of taping this he has over 30,000 a month
in pledges.
I'm beyond thrilled for him as a creator but
more so as a friend.
It was only 10 days ago when he didn't know
if his career was over.
And I've been in the same boat myself.
Not only did Colin launch an incredibly successful
Patreon, but he's also made some stellar appearances
on Glenn Beck's radio show and last week was
on Joe Rogan's podcast.
I mention all of this because I view this
whole instance as a massive win for the free
speech, anti regressive movement.
We can no longer give these hysterical people
an inch because they won't stop taking until
we've all silenced ourselves.
Obviously many of you see this and agree with
it, which is not only why our interviews did
incredibly well but also why so many of you
put your money where your mouth is and joined
Colin on Patreon.
And by the way I should welcome our new Patrons
as well because we got a bump in the midst
of all this as well.
This isn't about money though, it's about
taking back the narrative from people who
use buzzwords and outrage to silence the rest
of us who are trying to have meaningful conversation.
Allies are popping up all over the place in
this space and it's only together than we
can full fight back the bad ideas which have
led us here.
From Colin to Joe Rogan to Phil DeFranco and
many others I see a new alliance forming of
content creators who aren't political per
se, but who will no longer be held hostage
by the same outrage machine that is crushing
dissent, not through conversation but by public
shaming.
We must now destroy the politics of destruction
if we're going to move forward.
I think we just got a major win and I look
forward to you joining us for many more.